[Music]
and get out of my head news get the [ __ ]
out
submitted by it's [ __ ] raw that is
either disgusting
oh that's Gordon Ramsay it's [ __ ] raw
oh oh a rare condition causes an 87
year-old solution hallucinate England's
national anthem on a constant loop one
new rare condition causes an 87 year old
- who thought you hallucinate sorry
that's gotta be a national anthem on a
constant loop because if somebody was
seeing our national anthem only meant to
be heard once that's it the second time
around kind of annoying
oh say Oh sing it sing the whole song
can you see by the dawn's early light
you are so unpatriotic yeah that is
terrible get the [ __ ] out of this
country it's been so long since I did
the Pledge of Allegiance when we had to
do it at the City Hall I was like oh
that's what I did I did justice for
justice for all are you so many kids in
class that's so funny
all right so this story is about an 87
year old British man oh he's old yeah
and so his name is Ron and he says that
he experiences these who auditory
hallucinations
Wow interesting he has this rare
condition called musical
your syndrome people say that's when
they lift the baby you didn't watch
Family Matters really Buerkle no wait he
was too cool by that no guys I'm a part
of this group so this condition that he
has it's the rare kind the rare kind
it's called musical ear syndrome or mes
and it mainly affects people that are
suffering from hearing loss so it
usually is developed in like older
people that they have hearing loss and
so it's called non psychiatric auditory
hallucinations and so they're saying
that this affects approximately 1 in
10,000 people aged over 65 in the UK in
the UK
they all hear the national anthem that's
a statistic gosh it's hard that's the
statistics but think that is the that's
the Cystic that's the statistics ok
certificate they gave in the article
yeah so Ron is saying that this is so
this is a British anthem in case you
guys don't know
when I heard this what do you do wait I
want to be respectful do you do this I
don't know I think like this thing like
this with the teacup do they do this
what is America
untreated
yeah it's ours it's the star-spangled
banner no no my country tis this is the
mother country see wait a minute we just
stole their [ __ ] we stole their [ __ ]
don't tell me that we just took tinkle
twinkle little star and turn it into
ABCDE
pear talking [ __ ] what happened over
there cuz a twinkle my country too
[Music]
we're a bunch of [ __ ] biters dude I
know I did not know that was the British
yeah national anthem how dare we just
take those [ __ ] notes and just reboot
the words on we did that did we do that
I think we're a lot of assumptions going
on we're a cover country like the same
colors from the British fire has made a
difference Oh what's the why don't even
know what the British side looks like
the people that came that came here red
coat art what the lobster back yeah why
do we celebrate Thanksgiving there who
are the folks that came here were they
from the English yeah right so then
doesn't that make sense no because we
had an independence but then it makes
sense that a lot of the ships borrowed
is my Poland come on but like the exact
notes though I get what you're saying
the exact notes see we're because the
star-spangled banner is original right
so they could have made the next couple
of songs also original notes too I think
that person was just so [ __ ] lazy
there ya go just take you know that so
mind blown right now just put the words
out I don't think this song's gonna go
viral perfectly fine there's no UTS is
mind blowing there I wonder if that was
staged I hope that we say yeah it is
stages he thought pleasant this is the
other one that they had well I think
that was just as bad as the other is it
Cobb me still [ __ ] here yeah he he
hears this song over 1700 times a week
Wow
why can he hear people talking to him
although you said he's deaf oh he's he's
experiencing hearing loss like slowly so
initially when he started
hearing the anthem in his head he
thought it was his neighbor that kept
playing it cuz he got woken up and he
was like so you finally complain you
like dude it can you stop playing this
song and he was like it's a phrenic dude
you might have a mental disorders what
do you have very patriotic musical your
I know that's a read you guys had one
song that had a constantly play in your
ear for the rest of your life what would
it
that's a good question man oh let me
think about that one I don't know I
think it'd be a song with no lyrics oh
my I got one don't don't worry baby
by the Beach Boys there it is it's so
calming yeah after a while it's gonna
piss you off
I mean anything's gonna be probably the
brother is somewhere over the rainbow
it's really chill my hearing it over you
know what about the choose one right I'd
rather see some kind of chill what about
you
cuz you're the you're the music man get
[ __ ] over I can't anything repeat its
but you have to choose one no I know
which one it would be it would be no no
it would be no it'd be Queen Bohemian
Rhapsody oh just because there's so many
like variations yeah that's a difficult
song to sleep too it is I'm [ __ ] but I
need some variation though what you want
maggot brain cuz like after cuz Casey
and I will put that song on repeat some
times and we'll just listen to it over
and over in just like it has so much
emotion and like you feel the emotions
in that song and I feel like I could
probably listen to that song forever cuz
it's like a super long ass on tithing is
like 12 minutes
will you those nature soundtrack don't
have to be Awards yes have word
megaBrain only have words in the
beginning of it it has that words have
to have word hasn't he pop music well
not pop you just have to have words I
mean technically everything on the
radios pop or if it's hip-hop rock
country it's pop means it's popular
music hmm you me yeah I would choose
Ella Fitzgerald's version of I've got a
crush on Tina oh I like Marilyn no
question you sweetie pie
no no way never mind thank God sounds
classy though it's just so I got [ __ ]
with that also what a loved one dies you
hear that in your here I think I know it
would be I'm gonna change what a
difference a day yeah that would be my
clothes are waiting some more vince
guaraldi that um Charlie Brown Christmas
oh do Christmas songs as I clearly
so call me yeah I'll be the web then
this Christmas I'll give him hot oh yeah
yeah that's a good one yeah well
someone's gonna be fans gonna make a
compilation for you okay last Christmas
I gave my heart I think any song if you
repeat it it'll drive you [ __ ] reason
now this poor guy has been dealing with
this for three to four months
oh he try to listen to other music no
but it's in his mind it's in his home I
get this but it's--but fourth music he
says the way like he tries to cope with
it and it helps him is when he puts a
hearing aid in one year and then he has
a TV in the background distract it yeah
have you guys ever had this when you
think of a song and you turn on your car
and the [ __ ] song is on you're like
I'm telepathic [ __ ]
I got radio waves going in my brain I
feel like that when I was really really
young girl I used to record songs with
the cassette player oh yeah on the radio
yeah and I would be anticipating the
next song coming I'm like it's gonna be
this and I pressed record and then it
would be and then that's what I feel
like holy [ __ ] our powers it's also
because statistically it's highly
possible if you're listening to the top
40 you have 1 out of 40 chances yeah
it's not magic No